I'm at God at a church called Christ
Church in Nashville the pastor of that
church that led me the Lord my spiritual
dad we called him brother Hardwick his
name is LH Hardwick and several years
ago I had spoken literally at that point
all over the world
I've spoken to stadiums arenas just
about every major named large Church in
America I've spoken in and pastor
Hardwick asked me to come to Christ
Church to speak to their 2,000 3,000
people on a Sunday morning
it was nerve-racking because to say that
this man sits in a seat of Honor in my
life would be an understatement so he
and I are standing on the stage getting
ready to start the service he turned to
me just does that happen and he said
they do you know why most young pastors
fail at speaking at being great orators
and I said
no and I'm not sure why he's telling me
this at this moment why why I'm gonna
bail as his curtains going up oh my
goodness and he said because it becomes
humdrum to them they don't spend the
time that they would spend as if they
were speaking to a stadium as if they
were speaking to 10 million people on
the radio
and they don't have the excellence in
the ordinary now I'm not sure why he was
telling me that and I hope I did ok that
day I think I did because I've studied
my craft of speaking for a long long
time but boy that lesson coming from
someone that I think so much of meant so
much to me
excellence in the ordinary most people
don't win at life at certain areas of
their life not because of one big event
but they they get killed death by a
thousand cuts it's not one little thing
that runs a marriage it's not one little
thing that causes you to go into debt
it's not one mistake that that causes
you to be overweight it's not one meal
it's not one extra hamburger it's death
by a thousand cuts
we don't have excellence in the ordinary
so we've actually made that a core value
at our company because we want our
company to do that we want people
working on our team to do that as a part
of our culture but it needs to be a
reflection of our personal lives too so
what I'm challenging you to do today is
to be excellent in the little things
it'll change your life well change your
life on everything you start looking at
you mean give you an example you've been
married more than six or seven years you
hear people say date your wife don't
date your wife don't date your wife
that's one night a week or that's one
night a month that's our third night
that's the one night I'm gonna treat her
like I used to treat her when I was
courting her now crap court your wife
that's an old-fashioned term isn't it
court your husband you remember how
excited you used to be when he came
around when you were dating when you're
recording well you were engaged you were
flirting you were romantic you were your
pulse rate changed and you know what
that's a decision and you don't take
people for granted when you have when
they walk in the room and you go when
you meet somebody famous you go you
could do that with your spouse couldn't
you you you could apply this kind of
thing to any area of your life your
spiritual life you know going to church
can just become going to the country
club today it's about the same thing but
maybe you need to become maybe you need
to be in all of God again I mean need to
be in all of the opportunity that in
America we are free to gather and
worship our Creator maybe we need to be
excited about that like you were when
you first met God be on fire about
something again and that causes you then
to be excellent in the ordinary take
ordinary things dump excellence on them
and you'll change your life